it was such a high profile and expensive
Mission they just couldn't afford to
fail
something like 10 000 people in 14
different countries have contributed to
making the project happen
the Breakthrough of the year is a prize
where we pick the bit of science that
has made the biggest impact that year
the topic we decided on for this year is
the James Webb Space Telescope or jwst
as we normally call it
it sees the universe an entirely new way
they first started talking about what
the next mission would be back in 1989
so that was before Hubble even left the
ground the Hubble Space Telescope our
window on the universe
that really solidified some years later
when Hubble first created a Deep Field
image they found that this empty bit of
sky was full of galaxies and they
realized they could see much further
back into the history of the universe
than people had thought
so astronomers needed an infrared
telescope to be able to study these
galaxies and see a lot of them where did
wst wins over Hubble Is by being able to
observe it much longer infrared
wavelengths a Hubble Is about sort of 1
6 the collecting area of jwst
Hubble can't see the most distant
galaxies without that infrared component
[Music]
infrared is also important for studying
exoplanets the mission like Kepler
measures a bunch of colors jumbled
together like white light
[Music]
jwst provides us with this new way of
looking at exoplanets by studying the
constituents and the properties of their
atmospheres it's looking at these
dimmings of light in hundreds of colors
all at once in the infrared
to do the science that they wanted to do
required technologies that had never
been done before in a Space Telescope so
the cost estimate kept going up the
launch date kept being getting pushed
back in 2011 Congress threatened to
cancel the whole project also I think
there's a fundamental question not for
me but for the country at large and
including some of our colleagues of why
we're doing this it was you know
definitely threatened and on life
support for a little while Congress gave
it a reprieve but they set an absolute
budget maximum and a firm deadline and
NASA had to keep to that
it sort of defies the imagination that
you could get this thing into space
because it looked so huge
then there was the long process of
loading it into a container and putting
it on a ship and sending it to French
Guiana where it was launched on an
Ariane rocket from the European Space
Agency
James Webb begins a voyage back to the
birth of the universe
from the moment of launch which is on
Christmas Day it all just seemed to go
perfectly
there were something around 350 possible
failures where a single object could
fail and it would [ __ ] some part of
the mission the fact that so much stuff
was out of my control meant that I
wasn't as anxious as I as I might have
been I did feel very nervous I couldn't
really fathom that everything would work
when you're pushing technology and
you're doing something for the very
first time there's always the unexpected
as they were commissioning it up in
space while it was on its way to its
station they were ticking those off and
we have a fully deployed jwst
Observatory they were getting more and
more relaxed as time went by
it wasn't until July that we actually
got a Peak at the very first data we saw
the Spectrum from the atmosphere of a
planet called wasp 96b and we were
watching this on NASA TV but
simultaneously we were running the
calculations from the simulator that we
used before Web launched we're looking
at the dots on the screen and the error
bars and we compare them to what we saw
on our computers and they matched almost
exactly
that's when I knew that jwst was going
to deliver on its promise that it was
going to give us
precision
that means that everything we proposed
to do with the telescope in just the
first year we were going to be able to
do
right after the release of those early
observations our first exoplanet was
observed
we saw the carbon dioxide we saw carbon
monoxide and then we saw this molecule
sulfur dioxide
[Music]
first detection of a molecule in an
exoplanet that also requires
photochemistry the very first image that
was released was this Deep Field image
JW's tea was pointed at an empty patch
of sky and left looking at it I think
for 12 and a half hours now remember
that Hubble Deep Field images took
hundreds of hours scientists have also
found some of the most distant galaxies
that have ever been seen in the infrared
in that first image so it was already a
groundbreaking when it came out
I think it's gonna be incredibly
exciting what we're going to learn about
the very earliest galaxies in the
universe
it's just amazing how once you start
observing in the infrared how galaxies
pop out the infrared can cut through
some of the Interstellar dust and show
you stuff that you just can't see with
Hubble
the parts of jwst are all working better
than we could have hoped the original
requirement for the jwst lifetime was
five years with a goal of 10 years by
using less fuel during the launch in
Ascent part that means there's more fuel
left for this station keeping the
station keeping fuel looks like it could
easily last 20 to 25 years knowing that
the spacecraft will last for 20 years
but you're talking about hundreds maybe
even over a thousand exoplanets that
will have atmospheric Diagnostics that
will tell us a lot about how planets
form and evolve
whenever people have built a new and
better instrument they've always
discovered things that they didn't even
imagine having the sort of information
they're getting now which they've never
had before is gonna bring you know huge
advances
it's just going to have such a
transformative effect on astronomy
[Music]